[music]
Mark Zondlo:
My name is Mark Zondlo, and my head is in the clouds.
I'm measuring water vapor on the vertical-cavity surface-emitting laser hygrometer.
[airplane engines]
Mark Zondlo:
In a 21st-century version of Captain Cook's historic voyage, we are exploring the atmosphere from
pole to pole in a flying laboratory. We porpoise through the skies, taking readings from 14 kilometers high
Mark Zondlo:
to just above the sea ice.
[music]
Mark Zondlo:
This National Science Foundation project, called Hiaper Pole to Pole Observations, will
give us the most comprehensive picture yet of greenhouse gases and how they affect climate.
Mark Zondlo:
Our journey includes Alaska, the Arctic, Hawaii, the Cook Islands, New Zealand and Antarctica.
[music]
Mark Zondlo:
Why clouds? They can warm the earth, they can cool the earth, but we don't know how they form,
and water vapor holds the key.
Mark Zondlo:
In discussions about global warming, carbon dioxide and methane get all of the attention,
but water vapor impacts climate more than any other gas.
Mark Zondlo:
We've invented a laser-based sensor that measures water vapor throughout the atmosphere.
What's neat about it is that it actually sticks outside the aircraft and allows for real-time,
Mark Zondlo:
precise and pristine measurements, and it's plug-and-play.
[music]
Mark Zondlo:
While we circle the globe, Princeton graduate student Minghui Diao analyzes the data in
real time. What we are finding is surprising. Large plumes of water vapor exist in areas
Mark Zondlo:
we never expected to find them. Learning how this fits into the puzzle is crucial for predicting
climate and making smart policy decisions. The atmosphere is perhaps Earth's last frontier.
[music]